Welcome to Module Six — object detection.
Now we don't just classify an image, we find and label every object inside it.
We'll cover the metrics, anchor boxes, suppression, and the YOLO family.
Detection is classification plus localization, repeated for every object.
The metric that grades a box is intersection over union — the overlap between prediction and ground truth, from zero to one.
Its smarter cousins, G-I-O-U, D-I-O-U, and C-I-O-U, add penalties for distance and aspect ratio, and as a loss they converge faster than plain L2 on boxes.
Most detectors start from anchor boxes — prior shapes tiled across the image at varied scales and ratios.
Each anchor predicts an offset, an objectness score, and a class.
Running k-means on your ground-truth boxes finds good priors, and stacking anchors across a feature pyramid handles multiple scales.
Newer anchor-free detectors like FCOS and CenterNet skip this step entirely.
Any detector produces a flood of overlapping boxes, so you clean them up with non-maximum suppression.
Sort by confidence, keep the top box, and drop anything that overlaps it too much.
Soft-NMS decays scores instead of deleting, and DIoU-NMS is a modern refinement — tune the threshold per dataset.
The YOLO family made all of this real-time.
It predicts on a grid in a single pass, with a head that emits objectness, class, and box offsets together.
Versions three through eight trade blows on speed and accuracy, and you can export any of them to TFLite or ONNX for mobile and edge.
To grade the whole system, use mean average precision.
Compute the area under each class's precision–recall curve, then average across classes — at I-O-U zero-point-five for VOC, or averaged across thresholds for COCO.
Always report it next to per-class F1.
Let's train a YOLO detector — open the labs.